اختبار حاسم تواجهه صفقه الرئيس الامريكيه
جو بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب
المتعلقه بسقف الديون مكان الاختبار قاعه
مجلس النواب اما الهدف فتمريره مشروع
القانون والحصول على دعم كافر من الحزبين
لتعليق حد الدين قبل الموعد النهائي اي في
الخامس من يونيو فاليوم يحضر التشريع امام
لجنه قوانين مجلس النواب التي تتكون من
تسعه جمهوريين واربعه ديمقراطيين عضوان
جمهوريان منهم بالفعل عارضا صفقه بحسب
وولد ورغم ذلك فان الرئيس الامريكي مرتاح
بل اكد انه يشعر بشعور جيد حيال ذلك لافتا
الى عدم وجود سبب لعدم التمرير في الوقت
المناسب لتجنب التخلف عن السداد في كلا
المجلسين يمكن لمعارضي مشروع القانون
ابطاء تمريره فالمحافظون يعارضون الصفقه
لانها لا تذهب بعيدا بما يكفي للحد من
الانفاق الفيدرالي بينما يصف تقدم يونا قي
ود الانفاق بالشديده للغايه وفي حال
الموافقه على مشروع القانون المقترح في
مجلس النواب فسيواجه جدولا زمنيا مضغوطا
في مجلس الشيوخ حيث قد يستغرق تمريره
اياما مع وجود مطالبات بتعديل بعض بنوده
[موسيقى]
اذا صفقت وسفقه سقف الديون التي يروج لها
بايضا ومكارسي قد تواجه حقل الغام
الجمهوري وديمقراطي يهدد مصيرها على ماذا
تنطوي اذا تعليق الالتزام بسقف الدين
البالغ حاليا واحدا وثلاثين تريليون و400
مليار دولار حتى يناير 2025 ايما يتيح
للحكومه الامريكيه سدد التزاماتها في
المقابل يتم الابقاء على الحد الاقصى
للانفاق التقديري غير الدفاعي عند مستويات
العام الحالي اي
936 مليار دولار في عام 2024
وزيادته بواحد في المئه فقط في العام الذي
يليه فيما يرفع الانفاق الدفاعي الى نحو
886 مليار دولار اي زياده بواقع 11% عن
المبلغ المخصص في الميزانيه الحاليه اتفاق
حد الديون يشمل نقل التمويل الخاص لدائره
الايرادات الداخليه ومن شان قطع ما قيمته
مليارا من اصل 80 مليار دولار مخصصه
لتعزيز انفاذ الضرائب وايضا تحديث
تقنياتها خلال عشر سنوات وفق نيويورك
تايمز في الاتفاق ايضا استعاده نحو 30
مليار دولار من الاموال غير المستخدمه
والتي كانت مخصصه لكورونا وتتراوح قيمتها
الاصليه بين 50 و 70 مليار دولار فبعيدا
ومكار في اتفقا على قواعد جديده لتسريع
المراجعات تسهيل التصاريح لمشاريع الطاقه
وهي اولويه جمهوريه في محاوله لجعل
التغيير اكثر قبولا للديمقراطيين من
المتوقع ان تلغي الصفقه متطلبات العمل
المحاربين القدامى وحتى المشردين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات